alright so here we are guys it's just
starting off where we left off last
episode so pretty much we are starting
episode 4 within ten point six mil I do
believe and that is the total indeed
however I will try to keep these
episodes a bit shorter just because it
allows me to upload more per week and
allows me to just pretty much have all
my merges in one and it's not really
long and drawn out so this is going to
be a probably a shorter episode but hope
then get a good amount of progress done
within it so if you guys enjoy the video
at the end obviously feel really would
like if you guys have any constructive
criticism feel free to leave in a
comment down below and if you want to
see more feel free to hit that subscribe
button nonetheless let's get right on
into the merchants here we haven't
killed it set but now i'm going to list
it up for sick or 5 6 49 k to just get
my money back and then after that then
we will be in the profits but damn time
there we go so go let's gilded homicide
gold gilded such a soul to rena buyback
another one alright so i just got back
from work I was trying to buy all these
things for certain prices you tried
Salman it sets for a huge profit I
didn't think I undercut the price is too
bad I thought I might actually be able
to do that but I end up getting to Gilda
for homes so we're going to buy one of
them but then we are going to sell the
other these two and the next one we're
getting at that price so let's go ahead
and throw in an offer for 900 k and i
will buy so 8 18 k which means i believe
i made about 38 k off of this which you
know isn't great but it's a little bit
of profit so can never complain about it
i did indeed make huh not 48 k not too
bad all right so here's kind of a sneak
peek of snake deed sneak peek of what i
do on me so there we go I just I'm
trying to flip these I was trying to do
them earlier however they were not they
just weren't cooperating so I left a man
over time so hopefully i can sell these
on for a little bit of a profit as you
can see i bought them for 4876 k i'm
going to try to sell them for four wait
for nine eight seven six there we go
alright so I'm going to try to sell them
for 50 and probably what like 200 k I'd
say I'd be reasonably so I thought these
would so pretty easily however
two of sold overnight which is kind of
strange I'm just going to try to sell it
for let's say what I bought it for so
we're just going to throw it down for
well as you can see there's one that
sold for 786 k of reason so we're just
going to throw it in 47 85k kind of
annoying that didn't sell but we're in
five other item and move swiftly on to
that alright so I want to go play soccer
and I was doing a lower merch such as
he's uncut diamond so I was able to buy
about 1,900 of them around there and
since I didn't all by I have confidence
their price went up a little bit so
we're going to look at uncut by the
diamond see how many one buys four and
one buys for 4053 which means i'll sell
all of these on and i will make about a
hundred a profit nice and Jesus Christ
nice and easy so it's a pretty quick
merch nothing too extraordinary but uh
not bad nonetheless huh well anyways to
be a good diamond sold there we go check
out how much cash we got 10.7 mill or
him check out the uncut diamonds bucket
all right so don't know what god I don't
know where I last left off with these
diamonds but some of them bond and all
of them is sold so we're just going to
collect all that take a look and we made
a little bit of money so we're at 10.8
gonna find another item and hopefully it
doesn't you know isn't a is these
diamonds were all right one of the
internal crystals have bought as you can
see there's a huge margin on it um I
don't know I didn't merch anything
overnight I tried to do some of that bot
dumping stuff and I chose to do raw
sharks and I actually raised overnight
so I wasn't able to grab any of them if
I would have known I would have made mad
prophet I don't know if also be able to
see it anyways they're 280 right now
they were to 30 last night so I would
have made 450k had i just bought them
all last night but uh you know things
happen well actually fell asleep for a
second but one of them bought one of
them sold so hopefully we can try and
sell this on again Jeremy for 195 k
was an elm and I'll take the L in that
one all right so scarily enough i was
able to buy one however not able to
settle one which is a little terrifying
I'm going to check out what the price of
eternal course was a is by the actively
traded price I want to try to throw them
up there for I think I'm just gonna go
mad with it and then hopefully those are
so long so both of my eternal crystals
have sold and also a bottom by pineapple
pizzas and BOTS we're gonna five one of
these just see what the prices so i can
show you guys kind of what i may not all
right so as you guys can see the price
went up to 10 42 which means i'm about
to make over a hundred GP on both of
these which means this is a 200k much
pineapple pizzas have sold and some of
bots so hopefully the price has gone up
on however the eternal crystals and did
not buy so we'll just have to merge into
something else once the cell or maybe
before that I don't know after I just
got reporting the last clip file some of
these have sold however one is still
just sitting there so we're gonna let
that one cell on I really don't care
nonetheless we have dragon arrow tips as
well which go for 13 11 and as you can
see they go for 1380 i'll double check
that just make sure and as you can see
they do actually go for 138 oh so 1229
from that so we did make like 60k profit
and then uncut diamonds we're going to
buy one of those it C 4 125 so we make
75 GP off of each of these which means
we make about 40k so we're gonna sell
them on for that and yeah that's about
if right now parents are not buying so
I'm just gonna cancel out those cancel
these just collect everything and so
we're at 9.6 whatever mill so we're
gonna sell these on for 4 125 anyway
it's just sold off my dragon Warhammer
474 mill 775 k so i made 475 k profit
nice nice not on that account at all but
this way you guys we look forward to
eventually now it is the morning
and our dragon arrow tips a soul which
is kind of the best thing because those
things take the longest to sell I saw
these were lower price and tried buying
that overnight didn't work so this
little more chewy on right here as you
can see i'm buying these for 4700 to
however they are selling forward that
but i might drop a little i'm gonna sell
them for like four seven nine the prices
of these kind of dropped a little bit so
right now buying for for 650 and i'm
selling for pretty much 1k above it
however i haven't sold any in a little
bit now these Snapdragon seeds have sold
so we can kind of look at that real
quick i'm gonna see if they have any
more margins on them though as you can
see though it's pretty much sold them
all for 47.4 k gonna explain something
real quick so basically i don't have 60
fire me on this account however i'm
gonna transfer over to my main don't get
upset with me but i found huge margins
and i want to kind of progress series a
little bit so look at this right here
but all these you see it's 83 literally
all you have to do is put it into a
sapling sell it on for 10k more which
means all these buy and sell as you know
i would expect but you know prices drop
and rise and whatever i'll be making 1.3
mail like that's insane literally cut
probably about five minutes later i have
water all of them got him to grow their
my they're my own now i've raised them
created them i'm gonna sell mine for 89
k hopefully they all in to sell and they
do indeed look at that 675 okay and i
bought them as you can see here for six
mil jeez is that the hell of a profit
i'm gonna keep doing this if I kick so
90 for torsional seeds have now is so
we're gonna take the money from that and
throw them into you seeds because I just
found out the margins down to 84 00 3
which still means that there's a pretty
fuggin decent profit on all this it
appears that the tour still see to have
sold I moved them down a little bit but
not a whole lot so he did make a decent
our money we were almost at who we are
at 12 now well I found the margin on the
gilded and then I bought and sold one so
right now we're even however once
another one buys now I have the prices
everything's easy here on out hopefully
um what I FK for a little bit however
both of these have bonds we're gonna
lift them up probably a little over what
I was initially listening about four ok
so both of the gilded sets have now sold
so we got our 12 mil back we're at 12.2
I believe and we are indeed imma find
some different items because those
things didn't merge very well at all now
my helms have bought so I'm going to
sell those back on you just look 29 oh
ok so we're gonna sell them on for that
now all of the Gotham Psalms have sold
for 11.6 mill swing kind of look right
there so 11.6 we bought them for 11 488
so 112 k pretty quick so i bought gilded
boots as you can see for 12 to five ok
on the OS buddy site it says i can sell
it for about 12 71st 12 mil 740 k so
hopefully that'll Solano make us a 500k
off of one item there we go so I went to
bed and the gilded boots sold for 12.6
mill which means we made 350 k on it
took actually quite a while so I don't
know if I was worth it by its the
biggest merchant thing I've had so far
the series though so we might be doing
more like this who knows it doesn't
provide a lot of content though because
it's kind of a real long-term merch so
now both of our eternal boots have
bought and sold I didn't expect there to
be really any margin on this but I
checked it out there's actually a 59 k
margin so we will be making a pretty
decent amount of money off of this it's
not it's not too shabby but uh we'll
just merge these for a little bit
hopefully we can make herself feel under
K now both boots have sold we made a
quick 220 k although we really didn't
make it because we actually bought one
pair of boots but we're gonna go throw
back some money into this obviously at
this point because you don't see eternal
boots they kind of failed after those
two no more bought or sold so instead I
went on to do some guns helm so I'm
going to throw these back in for 285
okay and we're about to make a quick
like probably 60 k something like that
so after about an hour and a half my
guns helms have sold not for barely any
profit at all I bought them for about 10
k less than that so I made 40k but
definitely not worth my time so I think
forget where we are going to end off the
video if you guys enjoyed feel free to
leave a like there's anything I can
improve on feel free to comment that
down below and if you guys want to leave
a sub and you'll be notified as soon as
my video goes up in the future
nonetheless hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace